the world champ the games of the world
championship matches had always caught
my attention they were the most
important premiere games and I valued
them above everything else and last year
there was a match between world champion
Viswanath Anand Anand and his young
challenger Magnus Carlsen from Norway so
I was really excited about this match I
thought it was going to be a close match
and I was really surprised by the result
and the fact that the result was so
lopsided because I thought for sure that
Vichy was going to win at least one game
and I thought it might be decided even
in overtime this game that Magnus one
with black really took the sails out of
the Xi's campaign to keep his World
Championship title so Vichy is white we
have a rule II Lopez and then we have
the Berlin defense variation so d2 d3 as
we saw in the match this ending the
so-called Berlin Wall didn't bring and
not much success he gets to this ending
and oops I'm sorry and white was not
breaking through okay so this ending has
been is a choice as a top choice of
today's top grandmasters and it seems
that black is actually doing well okay
be that as it may this she didn't break
through Magnus's defenses and he played
d3 so one of the ideas is behind the
move d3 is although it's a slow moving
for
what white does want to play is he does
want to play c3 and eventually he does
want to break break out and branch out
and play for d4 hi John welcome back
had a nice lecture over the world chess
Hall of Fame very good very good
okay so d3 Bishop c5 developing c2 c3 so
okay everything's fine for white and
he's he's going to castle he's going to
develop his pieces and he's looking for
an opportunity of playing d4 in the near
future
castles castles all of these moves have
been played a great deal rook e8 what
blacks idea behind this move rook e8 is
is that at some moment when white plays
the move d4 what black wants to put a
lot of pressure on the e4 pawn so the
rook slides over to the e8 file to the
e-file perming rook e1 a6 attacking the
bishop bishop drops back b5 bishop drops
back and now d6 okay so we've got a
normal Spanish rule elope as looking
position except it's a little bit
different many times in the Rui Lopez
the black Bishop is sitting on the e7
square in this particular case the black
Bishop is on the c5 square where it's a
bit more active and you might think that
there's a very good thing for black
probably it is but at the same time the
Bishop on c5 makes the advance d3 d4
that much more attractive for white
Bishop g5 advanced developing let's see
why why didn't why didn't white play the
move d4 what was wrong or was in fact
there anything wrong with the move d4
well one of the things is can black went
upon could black tain
take and play a move for example like
Bishop here let's say I played a move
Knight here and let's say you play tags
tags and let's say you take upon could
white win his pawn back the white
winners pawn back
do you see a way that white might be
able to win a spawn that apart meet
Queen e2 attacking the knight I probably
would play d5 defending the knight one
of the things that we could look at is
that we would like to play our Knight to
g5 and attack this pawn on f7 thanks to
our Bishop the Knight g5 he would take
our night with his knight so one of the
things that white could do is play
Bishop takes f7 check King takes f7 rook
takes rook tanks Knight g5 check so that
so white could win his Knight back but
actually there's even a nicer moved and
winning white could win his pawn back
but there's actually even a nicer move
for white here we kind of look and we
notice that these two Knights
this Knight especially is unprotected
this Knight is only protected by the
rook
so one of the moves that we should be
attracted to as bishop to defy then we
fork both Knights
how sweet it is right so we play Bishop
to d5 and we're very happy because we
think we're winning a piece and then
Knight takes c3 scares the bejesus out
of us the knight Forks our queen as well
as our Bishop but we forget to resign we
forget to resign instead we find a very
good move for white in this position
Bishop takes c6 we may lose our queen
but we get it right back after rook
takes Queen takes bishop takes and at
the end of a long variation one
two three one two rooks white ends up a
piece ahead so in fact in this position
after the move d4 white is not gambling
the loss of this pawn because he's going
to get a piece back the reason that this
she didn't play the move d4 right away
is the bishop drops back
the bishop drops back and white has
gotten the move in d4 great great really
really wonderful tempo winner but now
he's got a problem this pawn is under
pressure this pawn is under pressure and
with a future Bishop g4 the pawn the
pressure on the d4 pawn can be severe
that was why Vichy didn't advance the
pawn and instead chose the move Bishop
g5 but this is a kind of nice move to
right I mean the bishop on G Phi this is
a very awkward pin to say the least and
other variations of the Rui Lopez the
bishop is back here on e7 so this this
pin is not that important so with Bishop
g5 white is saying well if you do
nothing
I may just develop by 9 all the way over
to h5 I'm a co 92 to F 1 to G 3 to h5
you've got to do something about the pin
if you move your queen well then I'll
take your knight and double your pawns
so I've got you in a pin what you're
going to do about it
Bishop e6 could somebody tell me why
Magnus
did not play h6 and g5 breaking the pen
what do you think about that idea is
that a good idea for black
yeah yeah he's yeah
in the immortal words of Viktor Korchnoi
puns do not go backwards so after Black
has advanced one of the things white
black has to consider is white could
potentially sacrifice a piece for two
ponds the second thing is white could
just simply drop back with his bishop
and saying look what I've managed to do
is I've managed to make you advance the
pond shield in front of your kink
weakening your king
so Magnus did not play h6 and g5 instead
he played Bishop e6 one of the things in
chess and the great ideas of strategy of
chess is we always are weighing our
pieces are our pieces better than your
pieces are your pieces better than my
pieces and black reasons quite fairly
that this Bishop on b3 is on a very
active and good diagonal and this Bishop
is not so black reasons that it's in his
favor to want to trade bishops and hence
we see the movie six as a kid I was
always trying to ask myself questions
why did he do that why didn't you do
that why did he do that and so if I
found the solution even if it was wrong
it didn't matter if I found an
explanation for a move that I liked
okay that was good but I was always
asking questions why why didn't he do
that why didn't he do that so Bishop e6
answers this question that Magnus
believes that this Bishop on c8 is not
as good as the bishop on b3 who played
Bishop e6 9bd to h6 Bishop h4 and he
traded bishops now this she recaptured
the bishop with his a pawn and of course
I would ask the question why'd he do
that
well and I kind of I think I can answer
that question I think I could say well
he wanted to play a bb4 and he's hoping
that in the long term maybe by capturing
with the pawn he could prove that this
pawn is a weakness for black that's why
he took with the pawn
otherwise I would have probably thought
well why not capture with the bishop
captured the bishop with the knight
pardon me Knight takes the bishop would
drop back and maybe I could advance my
pawns in the center or prepare their
advance with everybody who played 8x b3
I'm just kind of curious yeah okay
8x b3 Knight b8 wow wow that's a retreat
can someone explain that one to the move
to me holy cow I thought that night was
pretty good there for a moment now he
just voluntary but he retreats it well
the answer of course has to do with this
idea that blacks in this uncomfortable
pin he doesn't want to solve the pin by
advancing his pawns and potentially
making us King very vulnerable rather he
Magnus reckons that his knight will be
better placed on d7 to help him sole the
pin of his Knight it cost him a lot of
time 1 2 moves in this maneuver of his
but Magnus reasons that the position is
pretty closed and so that he will have
the time to bring his knight to what he
believes will be a better position also
another way for Magnus to break the pin
is maybe to bring his knight all the way
to f8 + g6 attacking the bishop on h4
age 397 9h - these moves I didn't quite
follow I didn't understand the move okay
h3 I kind of understood but I didn't
quite feel the logic when vichy played
the move a - takes b3 what did you
expect that vichy would do before I
thought that this YZ idea was to play b4
drive the bishop back and then to try to
maybe double and put pressure on the a6
pawn so I was really anticipating before
and I didn't get that night h2 move so
what fishy is trying to do with Knight
h2 is to do something like Queen f3 it
maybe Knight g4 and increase the
pressure that this pin offers in my
opinion the move Knight h2 is a little
bit questionable and I would have found
myself more attracted to the idea before
pushing the bishop back Knight b3 and
trying to focus attention against the
pawn on a6 after all we played eight
eggs b3 to prove the pawn on a6 was weak
and now it's sort of like he's not doing
that
you played nine h2 Queen seven nine f1
okay this move I actually did understand
finally the Knight wants to come to e3
where there are two outposts on f5 and
defy that Beckett okay Bishop d6 this
move I understood as well black is
getting out of this tempo and maybe he's
ready to start to repositioning his
993 Queen b6 a skit escaping from Knight
d5 as well as from Knight f5 b4 finally
okay so again chess is about this
valuing pieces trying to decide who
who's whose pieces stand better and if I
was in black shoes I would reason that
White's rook on a1 is better than my
rook on h8 why why why isn't White's
rook on a1 better than that rook on a
eight yeah exactly and this rook attacks
this a5 and a6 squared so I'm reaching
deeper into blacks position than this
rook which is not attacking the a4 a3
square so as black I would be attracted
to the idea of a5 forcing a trade and
trading off my passive rook for active
rook it might take me a few moves but I
would be looking to play a five if I was
black this guy Magna is pretty good he
played a five at once tags takes so
Magnus reason that he wants he could
have recaptured with the rook rook takes
Bishop takes but he wants to keep the
tension over unknown on the a file wants
to keep the tension tags 94 Bishop goes
back to b6 all very very logical play
from both sides the bishop comes back it
wasn't doing any great shakes on this
diagonal on this diagonal it looks a lot
better
the night on h2 wasn't very good Knight
to g4 Bishop takes f6 Knight takes f6
Knight takes Queen so it's really funny
you know in all of those books it's you
that you you read over the course of
your lifetime one of the things that
really a lot of authors they seem to be
in a kind of a closed loop with one
another they always tell you a queen and
Knight is a better combination in Queen
and Bishop how many of you heard that
like the Queen and Knight work better
than the combination of Queen and Bishop
it's it's said so repetitively it's so
often you'd almost think gosh we could
stop right here and give white an
advantage he's established the advantage
of Queen and night over Queen and Bishop
but it's very specific that is a
principle not a rule if we look at the
position this Bishop actually is kind of
looking really good that bishops kind of
targeting the king we certainly cannot
jump with our Knight because the F to
pawn is hanging and maybe black when he
wants can simply trade off his Fischer
for net I don't see any reason that
white should be proud and to say I have
gained an advantage out of the opening
because I simply don't see it I think
the position is really really balanced
queen g4 well okay
finally the Queen comes out into the
game the rooks are connected queen g4
Bishop takes III mmm
Magnus as well I'll take that night off
the board after all bond takes and again
very very balanced position I kind of
thought that this game was going to be
heading for draw a pretty pretty soon
Queen e7 well from blacks point of view
he just wants to stop
an idea like Queen d7 that could
potentially attack this policy on b5 as
well as the pawn on c7 so Queen e7 makes
a lot of sense backing up and now
White's got a little bit of a problem he
does have double pawns okay it's maybe
not that critical but okay double pawns
rook f1 now here again I would start to
have some wondering what I'm supposed to
do I can't really advance this pawn to
d4
because after for example rook takes
rook takes pawn takes pawn takes the e
pawn is hanging so I'm not really
anxious about that but one thing I might
want to do is on the Queen side I might
want to consider moves like b4 and rook
a5 that was a thought that was going
through my mind as maybe I could try to
get a passed pawn I didn't think that
the move rook f1 was particularly
incisive it's sort of like oK you've
played rook f1 but what is the rook
really doing there as black I would
probably gain some space on the Queen
side now with c5 and maybe even things
like rook a7 after C 5 C 5 somehow I'm
channeling magnet I can see this so from
Magnus's point of view this makes
perfect sense he takes a little bit more
space and maybe he's got ideas like rook
a 7 and rook a 8 swimming in his head
just to try to win control over the a
file another thing he might want to do
is just take a look at his King side
right now there's nothing like that is
happening no doubling but I can see that
with g6 and King g7 these are nice small
incremental improvements of the play on
the King side the King is a little bit
better but it stands a little bit more
comfortably on the G sub
square then perhaps on the g8 square so
I can see nice small ways that Magnus
might want to improve his position maybe
even to try to play moves like B 4 B 3
and rook a to where as from White's
point of view white is drifting into a
position where there's some passivity in
his position if I was white in this
position one of the things I might want
to do is play moves like h4 and h5
setting up perpetual check possibilities
ok
and one thing I would want to be careful
about is and not to allow is a move like
c5 c4 so that I can't meet that move
with d4 because of my e4 upon hanging so
very very in small and small just
droplet like measures
it seems that blacks somehow and
perceptively is creating a better
position for himself in other words why
it's advantage if he had one has slipped
away completely and black might be for
choice I didn't like Michy's move King
h2 and like I said I would have probably
played a move like b3 and maybe c4 but
I'm almost certain I would have played
h4 and h5 as quickly as I possibly can
and that way I feel that I can I'm
securing the position for white king h2
c4
well there we go Magnus says if you play
d4 you got to consider that I may try to
win upon he said I have no choice I do
have to play d4 and Magnus traded rooks
traded rooks and now Magnus Otto think I
can Magnus take the pawn on e4 would
this bring him and
Vantage do we think that taking on d4
followed by taking on e4 would this be
good for black what do you guys think
what do you think I'll put another yeah
exactly so after trading Queens white
could very easily pick up the pawn on d5
by just going and simply attacking the
pawn and now if the white if the black
rook comes down a tank well I can defend
so this is a very easy position for
butta for a white to hold this work
ending is not a problem yes yes indeed
okay so but that was fine now in this
position
Magnus played the move Queen b7 and
again it's kind of this needle some
little move that puts the onus on white
because now suddenly black has ideas of
taking taking and instead of trading
Queens on e4 he wants to take with the
rook on e4 okay
so with this move Queen b7 now we're set
it we are set up as black to take on e4
rook d1 I wasn't again I'm not a big fan
of this move by Vichy we understand that
this she is worried about the potential
loss of his pawn on e4 but I wasn't a
big fan of this move in a funny kind of
way this she did not want to play
d 4 d 4 D 5 because very likely he felt
that his pawn structure wasn't very good
and while that's true I don't like the
double pawns I might like to
j'adoube my pawn from e3 to f3 in truth
it's extraordinarily difficult for black
to prove any kind of an advantage on his
side of the table in the first place if
you try to seize the a file
I'll trade I'll bring my Queen to d7 I
can guarantee you white is not losing
them when his queen is so very active if
black tries to go Queen b6 and go after
the pawn on e3 then after move like
Queen f3 again it's very very hard for
black to prove anything
to get an advantage so I thought d4 d5
even if it was positionally distasteful
would still be good enough to draw the
game rook d1 queen c6 queen fi these
moves were all played and now rook takes
now I thought already what what small
dollops of pluses that Magnus was
carefully nurturing had actually
blossomed now I thought that I
definitely would prefer blacks position
these two pawns on e4 and III are really
a quite weak and this pawn on d6 is very
hard to get at you know it's sort of
like you've got to bring your queen back
here you've got to bring your queen back
here and by that time it's pretty easy
for the for black to defend his pawn on
be sick rookie five Queen f3 Queen c7
okay so what Magnus is trying to do in
this case he's trying to warm his Queen
and set up a double set of a battery
pardon me against these pawns on e4 and
III and with this Queen on e7 you may
one day play f5 and rook takes III and
this Queen could swing up the ePHI even
so very very hard for black to to win
material King h1v she is now waiting
queen g4 king queen king so both players
waiting but once again I'm impressed
that Magnus makes a small incremental
improvement of his Kings position
everything's going very well
oh yes and here
massive confusion from me ah this move
Queen g3 when we keep putting pressure
on our opponents we keep forcing them to
answer issues they're human beings they
panic they fold they make mistakes I
didn't get this move Queen g3 at all I
thought that white should just be trying
to play I don't know Queen f4 and in
case of rook f6 I again I absolutely
acknowledge that black is for choice but
how on earth is is black going to win
material from this precise position it
wasn't clear instead vichy
saw a way of trading Queens and getting
into a drawn rook ending and I do
believe this rook ending is drawn but
black has a sunny side of the torture
he's the one who's upon
ahead so why not so if I was black I
said okay I'll sign up for that rook
defy very important move attacking the
pawn at once
not allowing black the opportunity of
playing rugby to activating his rook and
I'm sure when vichy sacrifice upon he
had this mental picture in his mind that
with his active rook he's got great
compensation he keeps blacks King from
warming himself around and so he thought
okay I'll sacrifice the pawn I'll be
slightly worse I've got a rook ending
yada-yada-yada
I'm sure I'm drawing it's not that easy
it's not that easy
f7 f6 strangely enough I actually didn't
like this move f6 I thought that Magnus
should have just gone King here King
here attacking the rook if the rook
maintains its station along the sixth
rank that vichy could then float his
rook here is rook here is rook here and
slowly slowly improve his position I
didn't think that the move f7 f6 was so
good the reason is because now these
pawns are somehow all nicely on the six
rank and vulnerable h5 I like this move
by vichy very much King and I like this
move by vichy very much
h5 now I was absolutely sure the game
was drawn this majority to pawn majority
is really the worst three-to-one
majority you could possibly have perhaps
with the exception of taking this f6
pawn and sticking it on h7 or h4 here
you get the triple pon formation and
that is a really lousy majority and I
thought that it the game was going to be
drawn very
shortly so all of these moves were
played pretty carefully
Cody simply and now enters one of the
strangest phases of an end game that
I've ever seen in World Chess
Championship history this this position
is a really easy draw if you took off
this pawn and this pawn you would get
the notorious F and H pawn and that is
drawn theoretically drawn but it's
virtually impossible for black to force
the trade of this H pipe on for this G
to pawn so anybody anybody who was
trying to draw this ending should simply
play the move b3 that's it simply play
the move
b3 check we're going to give black the
opportunity to do this and now we have
the worst majority we can get except the
Triple H bonds against this pawn on g2
again if I remove this pawn on h6 and
move this pawn on g2 we're in a third
theoretically drawn position but there's
no way that you can force this trade of
this pawn for this one if you like you
can go F or Anna I'm very very happy as
white to trade the fi pond for the g2
pawn and then it's a very simple draw of
King and H pawns versus rub in this
position but I would do if I was white
as I come over here and check and make
it that much more awkward for black to
do anything with his majority this is
very very simply drawn it's it's it's
really really really hard for a class
player to lose this play this position
against a masked
the master with the extra pawn extra H
pawns would have a nearly impossible
task
when this she entered this ending upon
down there's no question in my mind that
he was ready to make a draw and then at
a certain moment he stopped and he
started to think well the position so
equal that I can do almost anything and
maybe maybe I should keep my chances
alive and he played this instead of b3
I'm absolutely convinced that b3 would
have drawn the game and I'm kind of
convinced that what vichy chose should
have drawn the game but a game black
Magnus some extra chances h4 rook check
King rook okay so it's still looking
very very very drawing rook behind rug
behind look behind check here here
now it's less less drawing again one of
the simplest things we could do is if we
would just take all of these three pawns
off the board
white would have no troubles making a
draw just checking and going rook h6
there's nothing nothing going on the
only problem is this extra pawn on c4
you've got to watch out that black might
play moves like h4 a partly h5 f for h3
and one day get a pass at pawn that's
the only danger that's the only possible
way that I could lose this game check
here rook c4 things are getting
interesting
Kenny 3 rook takes pawn heat now
suddenly Vic and of woke up and he woke
up to the smell burning bacon and he
realized it was his own
bacon that's being fried because now
he's shocked to awareness that what's
happening is black wants to play h3g
takes h3 move his rook away push push
push push his Kings perfectly placed
if these pawns were gone from the board
this would be an easy easy draw for
white light would play check and then
just come back and take one of these
pawns okay these pawns fun funnily
enough are now in White's way of making
a check okay so rook came across h3
takes what goes back game is over
it's really that simple the difference
between the activity of Kings is
absolutely clear white King on h2 is
passively out this King on e3 is like
omnipresent and again the these pawns
seem to be stuck in concrete boots
they're not moving and that F pawn is on
a high-speed highway to f1 push or check
King
for rook check King
threatening the Queen check still
threatening the Queen rook goes behind
good and this is where this she gave it
a rest
essentially if he tries to push his pawn
now it's too late
Queen check King takes tanks and it's
very easy for black the combination of
blacks King and rook to deal with
White's
past pawns Wow
I mean talk about squeezing blood from
stone I mean black really really didn't
have anything much to speak of and it
was only through the slight slight
slight mistakes that black got some kind
of small edge nonetheless Magnus goes on
wins the World Championship improves his
rating clearly the world's number one
player